I'm already very confused how we bungee
jumping out of a helicopter they have to
like attach that somewhere when they
kill whoever the malla copter annual
Smith clearly he survived I mean it's
really sad video and why are more people
know about this hey guys it's Greg album
I mean Hardy's reject nation yeah this
is Rene Rene Orioles back people
how you doing Rene I'm doing good doing
pretty good awesome this is the first
time we're talking today nope haven't
talked to today at all that's why I'm
asking her right now well Rene on
Instagram and Twitter or else she'll
never come back that's the way she
operates all about marketing out here
you have to all follow me mm-hmm and
also follow her blog and she's on clever
news Wow high profile over here have you
heard of a man named William Smith I
think I have historians talk many about
Williams Will Smith has a YouTube
channel and apparently he did this from
his YouTube channel yeah they're calling
this a YouTube original here in the
watermark but he does have a YouTube
channel Will Smith jump bungee jumps out
of a helicopter well sir that's not my
favorite actor but he's one of my
favorite celebrities because he's
actually it sounds weird but I really
feel like one day Will Smith will just
be a certified personal development
motivational speaker because he has so
much audio and so many interviews where
he gives such great advice on mentality
and work ethic and I'm sure this is
something where he's stepping out of his
comfort zone so he's like leading by
example the kind of things he talks
about I'm already saying that I'm
inspired from this video without having
seen it yet I'm scared I know it sounds
scary right I don't understand the
concept of bungee jumping outside of a
helicopter you know how it's usually off
of a bridge like let's say you know yeah
to a bridge we'll find out headphones
okay is it eight minutes I've seen
longer
you couldn't do it keep this oh my god
hey jokes out
[Music]
what a frightening situation to be in
man I'm so calm it's a little scary
that's where he's praying yeah oh he
does look scared you know what am i
daring you scared the things you'll do
perfuse he's like it's my stunt double
gonna get yours at the Greg can you no
no you might be right though and I might
be dead by now leave a comment down
below five minutes
I'm not getting nervous forehead
we did go big for your first youtube
video big well sounds first youtube
video not no yes Betty this is an actual
channel I need it check this out I'm
very confused
does he vlog like yeah people long yeah
this is what happens it's great for well
we're just hobby right into this I have
no idea how this is gonna work he's just
gonna show their as they go up
Oh No you're pushing 50 well
[Music]
oh my goodness
look I'm scared of flying when I'm safe
in a plane like yeah I know are you
gonna as I just stand on this side of
there too
this is making me anxious just watching
that some ways is competing the timers I
hear they're friends
[Music]
dude look at this guy's a freaking
inspiration man you can tell he's scared
but he's like he's proceeding with
confidence say hey you know face your
fears I guess
[Music]
it's waving goodbye this is the end
Oh
[Music]
oh my god
it would be cooler if you had two guns
is he attached to anything yet no you
guys no no not rené well where are you
gonna look when your [ __ ]
[Music]
it's scary just like you see Carlton no
Fresh Prince of conservation issues in
the far right eye was painted to this
going
okay
such a process no wonder it's eight
minutes are building a fans in summation
whatever video footage you guys are
getting it's not as good oh my god
I wish she was holding Jayden when he
did
it's gonna do that thing right before a
judge you can defensively
come on will
[Music]
see using second thought
[Music]
Wow no way
no way is this a thing people do
[Music]
Wow that's awesome
I have serious nipple chills right now
happy now the side grows happy feels
like he's alive it's just a good time
you gonna see Carl's in the middle oh we
got much fun that looks now it looks fun
it didn't look funny in 200cc the girl
I'm looking at down oh man he is the
[ __ ] this is crazy
she just doesn't this looks fun that
part was but the initial fall I could
not this looks like a scream others Jada
Pinkett who is this whole group of other
peoples I like how do they find them was
this unlike backstage
[Music]
he gets the best view in the world now
what did anyone here
and that's so cool he gets a whole 360
view nothing blocking it
[Music]
this is crazy well Tom Cruise jumps out
of airplanes no wow okay we're not at
Will Smith shoes oh it is a Grand Canyon
see I didn't think it was that makes
this so much words like that's funny he
says that because there's a quote I
heard from him was a corner of him like
the other side of fear is greatness so
everyone is safe from terror to posting
this look who is everyone oh that's his
wife who's that who isn't on the pink
that's not his kid
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
oh man I get it they get it [ __ ] this up
and get it been deaf just from this
market yeah like the helicopter has to
still be flying that's a lot
[Music]
I spent 10 million dollars to do that my
two biggest fears are Heights and women
[Laughter]
no its Heights and snakes are my are my
two biggest fears
yeah I saw a whole video about it on the
news when I was a kid I mean some woman
sat on a toilet oh I've heard that that
freaks me out yeah but like snakes
aren't my biggest my biggest fear is a
great white sharks I'm so scared of them
like I can't watch videos I mean the
odds of bumping into a great white shark
we some kind of Suicide Squad
I love his acting I do think he's an
amazing I love his famous rap songs
actually on his channel it's the first
time in years he did a rap song and it's
a bomb rap song really it's a really
cool rap song just for the record
directors make movies I make directly in
terms of like the amount of personal
development and motivational talks and
like I'm telling you there's so many
videos we were talking about
self-discipline earlier and he has his
whole audio I found last week all about
self-discipline I need that I need Will
Smith so tell me am i confusing him did
he do a song for the World Cup recently
or was that someone else I remember it
was someone that I'm like they make
music fill and then it was I believe
Will Smith yeah look that up I gotta
look that up that way the internet
doesn't come after me from wrong I
really want to watch the rest of his
videos Channel now I did not know Will
Smith had a YouTube channel and I think
that's so cool the YouTube is getting
these huge that's great well it's simply
because this is advertised as a YouTube
original and seem like Will Smith
started off just doing his own thing
putting up his own videos just for fun
and now it's evolved into an actual
thing where YouTube's like he's doing
man tricking Will Smith right here
yeah that's part of the reason why I
admire the guy so much because he's
willing to experiment enjoy is will
coming that's very common word yeah he's
there's no other word for it he's
willing to experiment he's constantly
going out there and stepping out of his
comfort zone and he's one of those
people that I feel that when he does
give these like motivational talks and a
random interview or whatever about
mindset and work ethic he's someone to
really listen to because he's constantly
leading by example this is a very
terrifying thing to do and you could
tell that he was scared a lot of people
would back out of it just when I'm on a
roll yeah having fun yet no can I climb
back over the south this is stupid
it's really worth it I don't understand
the point what am I really overcoming
here yeah what is this thing like rich
people do that's why we were watching it
because I've never heard of bungee
jumping from a helicopter yeah ever but
maybe we're just too poor
I've heard of rich people like killing
people for lawyers to have an outlet
good for a will man good for bigwhale
right here it's cool that um you know
Carlton's here talking about Will Smith
pointing at his daughter did she grow up
you know it's a common thing for
children to eventually become older the
other day and she was a child is that
his daughter this one I imagine so I
always forget your kids names too but
there's literally their names just with
other letters yeah yeah okay no tricks
Jade and Jade and then Willow will do
you guys make it way too confusing Keith
I get you want your kids to constantly
live in your shadow but come on you know
those kids are very talented the whole
family's just a giant ball of talent in
Ian sure they're all like going out
there doing doing what they can to make
their own name for themselves and it's
cool that him in Alphonso Ruby arrow are
still close buddies you know what's neat
about this might be seem weird to keep
talking about the people who are
watching but what's what's really neat
about this is a lot of actors who become
that big
I don't see Jennifer Aniston kicking it
with Matt LeBlanc but that would be
amazing because a friend three friends
reunion is a friend but Alfonzo Riviera
just kicking it with them shows like
they don't really seem like they work
together anymore but it's cool that of
how close they still must be for him to
be there there's no way they still
worked on what right well it seems like
Alfonso will do what gigs he can when
it's Will Smith's cracking jokes people
I'm sure he's a very talented working
guy it was a really really big show a
very long time he was the fact that him
and Will are still really close and his
whole family's here it shows that Will
Smith is someone who is all about like
anything he preaches a lot on this so I
don't know if it's a clever marketing
thing he's actually doing but the fact
that he has his family here is close
friend front and center a lot of this is
just a big resemblance of his character
to me I like that everyone is dressed
like they didn't know this is where they
were the Grand Canyon today people
everyone's pretty casual for the most
part it seems like they're kind of like
hey come over here a little bit with the
stand right here get your iPhone's ready
and they had no idea what was coming for
them this should just be a new
promotional thing you do for the grant
can have you been to the Grand Canyon I
have actually that's why I'm very
disappointed that in the beginning of
this video I didn't think it was it
didn't look as red as it usually does I
blame the Grand Canyon for that yeah
yeah I couldn't even tell them so blame
them you can pay for like extra things
to do some stuff within the Grand Canyon
but this would be a cool offer if you
guys that yeah not even close to what
they offer well you're on my brother's
channel a long time ago so let's talk
about our point of views on cheating yes
shall we okay I know this is find that
video people guys what's your favorite
Will Smith thing is it his channel is it
his movies is it his music comment below
hey subscribe to the reject nation Renee
Arielle is on a lot of stuff go follower
links in the description box do it
immediately click the notification bail
because subscribe buttons suck take care
of people